hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
lieben Freunde ich liebe Tiere
ich liebe Hunde ich liebe Alpakas Liebe
Delfine Erdmännchen Koala es gibt so
viele wundervolle Tiere Giraffen auch
super Tiere und eine Sache die ich als
Tierfreund niemals machen könnte wäre
selber ein Tier erschießen
und dem ganzen stelle ich mich heute
denn wir spielen in der Hunter call of
the wild
[Musik]
oha
voll schön
hier chillen wir jetzt die nächsten Tage
oder was
unheimlich schönes wirkt ein bisschen so
wie ein Horrorspiel das gleich so
Zombies kommen aber es ist tatsächlich
ab 0 schwimmen gehen
[Musik]
anscheinend nicht Laser Luca 69 ist KO
gegangen bist
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
ich glaube das mir ploppte ein bisschen
zu viel auf diese Impulswellen die da
links gerade übrigens eingeblendet
wurden ich glaube die sollen darstellen
dass durch meinen Schuss irgendwo hier
in der Ecke Tiere aufgeschreckt sind
dementsprechend
sollten wir leise und vorsichtig
vorgehen
er sieht jetzt nicht aus wie ein Tier
ein biersch weiß Wedel hier die Spur
geht hier vorne auf jeden Fall noch
weiter
bzw ja wieder weiß weder hier ist okay
er ist in die Richtung gelaufen das ist
ja interessant okay also wir müssen
jetzt einen weißwedel hier entdecken
hier ist er lang gelaufen ist der
kreuzen
vorne geht's auch noch weiter
ich komme ziemlich gut klar Alfonso
ich glaube ich daneben geschossen
[Musik]
ich meine
stellt euch mal vor
ich würde mich
jetzt plötzlich
und da wäre kein Ass sondern Zombie
warum hat ihr gerade ein Stück geknackt
hier vorne haben wir auf jeden Fall auch
noch Spuren die gehen in die Richtung
und hier haben wir
weitere spundigen
keiner hat gefragt Bruder
[Musik]
in 70 Meter Entfernung hat mich eine
Schwarzbär gerade entdeckt
gewinne ich wieder an den See da gehen
ja dicker das ist doch alles laut wie
sein
[Musik]
schwarzbärs auf der Flucht ah ja auf der
Welt besser
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also ich habe mich erst so
einen Bahnhof von einem mediterranen
Truthahn den kann ich mir jetzt sowas
von ein Tier hat dich gehört bleibt mir
am Boden und meine Blattwerk und
möglicherweise die ganze Zeit so
rumlaufen oder was
sorry ich habe mir das Spiel mit ein
bisschen mehr Action vorgestellt ich
wusste nicht dass ich hier die ganze
Zeit einfach kraulen muss
perfekt jetzt plötzlich in die Richtung
oder was
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
dieser verdammte Truthahn Alter habe ich
mich erschrocken also das Spiel ist
wirklich sehr komplex ihr seht ja schon
wenn ich jetzt hier durchlaufe
hört man die Blätter ich muss auch sowas
meiden wenn ich hier Durchlauf
hört man hier ebenfalls Blätter ich habe
einen noch mal ein Truthahn der wird
sowas von gekillt jetzt wenn so Sachen
blau leuchten sind das wohl frische
Spuren ja fressende Truthähne okay die
sind hier also irgendwo da oben haben
wir auch noch irgendwie so einen neuen
Ort da können wir gleich auch mal hin
und können schauen ob wir von da so ein
bisschen hier über die Welt rüber gucken
können dann können wir nämlich die ganze
Zeit einfach nur da oben chillen
genau da sehe ich uns mit so einem
geilen Kaffee einfach runter gucken ein
paar Braunbären und diese blöden Todten
[Gelächter]
ist schon wieder mediterraner Truthahn
[Musik]
den getroffen
ich habe verdammtes Deo dabei
wir gehen auf die Aussichtsplattform
[Musik]
wir sind an einem Aussichtspunkt hier
vorne können wir auf jeden Fall
reingehen und haben
Werbung dann haben wir vor noch eine
Pfanne ach das ist richtig schon
überlebensspiel oder was und wir können
uns dann hier unser Essen rein beraten
oder wie
geil können wir auch das Öl nehmen den
ganzen Wein Wald abfackeln so oder so
können wir einmal komplett hier außen
rumlaufen und vorhin standen wir da
unten als erstes entdeckt habt hier
vorne habe ich irgendwo den Vogel
abgeschossen der ist dann irgendwo hier
runtergefallen haben wir da nicht mehr
gefunden da lag ein braunbärcher da war
und jetzt ähm
[Musik]
ja
von da sollte man nicht nach hier
springen
[Musik]
guck mal da hinten fliegen die Vögel Weg
das ist ja sehr wild was habe ich noch
so für Sachen ich habe noch eine
Schrotflinte
alles dabei mein Sniper okay das kannten
wir schon wir haben unser Deo natürlich
sehr wichtig wir haben unsere Flöte
[Musik]
und wir haben noch
in den zweiten Teil von sehen wollt dann
lasst einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nichts verpassen zum Abschluss würde ich
sagen
[Musik]
ich dachte es wäre eine Granate
ach wir haben nein wir haben Fernglas
wow
wir haben Fernglas
wieso erfahre ich diese ganzen Sachen
erst jetzt am Ende
haut rein